T
MAKE ANY SENSE.
THANK YOU.
FROM BASEBALL TO BASKETBALL.
THE WNBA STAR CENTER
BRITTNEY GRINER HAS BEEN
DETAINED IN RUSSIA AFTER POLICE
FOUND VAPED CANISTERS WITH
CANNABIS OIL IN HER LUGGAGE.
SHE PLED GUILTY AND SAID THAT
SHE PACKED THE CARTRIDGES
ACTIVELY.
GRINER APPEARED IN A RUSSIAN
COURT TODAY BUT NO VERDICT WAS
REACHED.
HER NEXT APPEARANCE IS IN HOURS
AND SHE FACES TEN YEARS IN A
RUSSIAN JAIL.
WHILE LeBRON JAMES WHO NEVER
MET A MOMENT BASH THE COUNTRY
THAT MADE HIM A MILLIONAIRE
DIDN'T LIKE OFFERED THIS.
>> SHE'S IN RUSSIA.
SHE'S BEEN THERE OVER 110 DAYS.
HOW CAN SHE FEEL LIKE AMERICA
HAS HER BACK?
>> I WOULD BE FEELING LIKE, DO I
EVEN WANT TO GO BACK TO AMERICA?
>> Laura: UNREAL.
JOINING ME NOW IS ENES KANTER
FREEDOM, FORMER CENTER FOR THE
BOSTON CELTICS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
ACTIVIST.
YOU ARE HERE BECAUSE YOU HAVE A
MESSAGE FOR BILLIONAIRE
LeBRON JAMES.
WHAT IS IT?
>> HERE'S --
WHEN I SEE PEOPLE TAKING THEIR
FREEDOM FOR GRANTED, IT BREAKS
MY HEART.
I WISH I CAN JUST BUY A PLANE
TICKET AND TAKE IT TO SOME OF
THE COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD
AND HE WOULD APPRECIATE IT MORE.
WHEN I HEAR HIS COMMENTS, I WAS
NOT SHOCKED.
I WAS LIKE WELL, HE HAS BEEN
HATING ON THIS COUNTRY FOR A
LONG TIME.
THE IMPORTANT THING IS WE SHOWED
PEOPLE.
IT KILLS MY HEART WHEN I SEE
COMMENTS LIKE THIS BECAUSE THE
THING IS THERE ARE OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD SUFFERING SO MUCH.
THEY ARE GOING THROUGH SO MANY
TOUGH TIMES.
I WISH I CAN SHOW THEM WHAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING THROUGH.
>> Laura: HE KNOWS.
THE MAN HAS BEEN TO CHINA TO
PLAY BASKETBALL.
HE FAMOUSLY GOT UPSET WHEN
ANYONE WOULD CRITICIZE CHINA OR
JEOPARDIZE THE NBA RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE COMMUNIST PARTY OF
CHINA.
HE KNOWS FULL WELL THE WAY OTHER
PEOPLE LIVE THAT HE DOESN'T CARE
SO YOU'RE BEING VERY CHARITABLE
HERE TONIGHT.
LeBRON DID TRY TO CLEAN IT UP.
HE TWEETED "MY COMMENTS WEREN'T
KNOCKING OUR BEAUTIFUL COUNTRY.
I'M SIMPLY SAYING HOW GRINER IS
PROBABLY FEELING EMOTIONALLY
ALONG WITH SOME OF THE OTHER
EMOTIONS.
LONG STORY SHORT
#BringHerHome.
"DO YOU BUY THAT?
>> EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT IT'S A
WALK BACK.
YOU DON'T GET A LOT OF BACKLASH
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
HIS PR TEAM IS TRYING TO CLEAN
IT UP BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO
WORK.
HE NEEDS TO UNDERSTAND
BRITTNEY GRINER WROTE A LETTER
TO PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN WROTE A LETTER
BACK TO HER AFTER SHE WAS
CONSIDERING NOT TO PLAY THE
NATIONAL ANTHEM THE REST OF THE
YEAR OF THE WNBA SEASON.
I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON.
LeBRON JAMES, HE EARNED HIS
MONEY IN THIS COUNTRY.
HE EARNED HIS RESPECT, HIS FAME,
THIS COUNTRY GIVES YOU
EVERYTHING AND YOU ARE AN
UNAPPRECIATIVE BILLIONAIRE AND
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
>> Laura: A WRITER CAME AFTER
YOU TONIGHT SAYING ENES FREEDOM
HAS A LOT OF NERVE.
HE WAS CRITICAL OF
LeBRON JAMES WHEN HE COULD
HAVE BEEN BRITTNEY GRINER OR
WORSE."
TURKEY REVOKED YOUR PASSPORT FOR
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST THEIR
DICTATOR AND YOU WERE STUCK
OVERSEAS WITH NO WAY BACK TO
AMERICA.
I SHUDDER TO THINK WHAT WOULD'VE
HAPPENED.
IT'S HARDLY WORTHY OF A
RESPONSE.
IT'S SO STUPID THAT IT'S FUNNY.
>> OH, MY GOD.
I STAND UP FOR THE TEAMS I
BELIEVE IN.
I LOST MY FAMILY.
2015.
I WAS SPEAKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS HAPPENING IN TURKEY.
I DID PAY THE PRICE.
WE ALWAYS SAY DON'T JUST TALK
ABOUT IT.
BE ABOUT IT.
TWEETING ABOUT IT IS FINE AND
GIVING INTERVIEWS IS FINE BUT
WHAT KIND OF SACRIFICES ARE YOU
MAKING?
WHEN YOU CALL YOURSELF A HUMAN
RIGHTS ACTIVIST, SOCIAL JUSTICE
WARRIOR, YOU CANNOT BE SIGNING A
DEAL WITH THE HYPOCRITE COMPANY
LIKE NIKE WHEN YOUR SHOES ARE
BEING LITERALLY MADE BY SLAVES
IN CHINA.
THAT'S ON ACCEPTABLE.
I DID PAY THE PRICE.
WHAT ABOUT LeBRON?
>> Laura: WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
SOME OF YOUR FORMER FELLOW
PLAYERS, I IMAGINE THERE'S A
DIVERSITY OF THOUGHT ABOUT ALL
OF THESE ISSUES.
YET PEOPLE ARE AFRAID TO SPEAK
OUT, AREN'T THEY?
>> OH, MY GOD, YES.
I REMEMBER FIRST TIME I STARTED
TO SPEAK OUT ABOUT THE PROBLEMS
HAPPENING IN CHINA, ONE OF MY
TEAMMATES WALKED UP TO ME IN THE
LOCKER ROOM AND SAID YOU KNOW
THIS IS YOUR LAST YEAR IN THE
LEAGUE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO PLAY
BASKETBALL AFTER THIS YEAR.
IT'S OVER FOR YOU.
I WAS REALLY SHOCKED.
I'M LIKE, WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
WHEN YOU CRITICIZE CHINA, YOU
COULD AS SIZE NIKE, YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO GET ANOTHER JOB AFTER
THIS.
I WAS SAD.
I TRIED TO REACH OUT TO SO MANY
OTHER NBA PLAYERS.
NOT JUST THE ENVY OF OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS, ASSOCIATIONS,
OLYMPIANS.
IT WAS RIGHT BEFORE THE BEIJING
OLYMPICS.
I WAS LIKE LISTEN, THERE'S A
GENOCIDE HAPPENING WHILE WE ARE
DRIBBLING THE BASKETBALL HERE IN
AMERICA.
PLEASE JOIN ME.
LET'S MAKE THIS MOVEMENT.
WHAT THEY SAID BROKE MY HEART.
THEY SAID WE LOVE YOU.
WE SUPPORT YOU.
WE JUST CANNOT DO IT OUT LOUD.
I ASKED THEM, WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
THEY SAID WE HAVE SHOE DEALS,
ENDORSEMENTS, JERSEY SALES.
WE WANT OUR NEXT PAYCHECK.
I ASKED ONE SIMPLE QUESTION.
PUT YOURSELF IN THEIR SHOES.
YOUR MOTHER, YOUR SISTER COMING
HER DAUGHTER WAS IN THOSE
CONCENTRATION CAMPS IN CHINA
GETTING TORTURED AND RAPED EVERY
DAY.
THEY HAVE A HUGE PLATFORM.
THEY ARE PICKING MONEY OVER
MORALS AND PRINCIPLES AND
VALUES.
>> Laura: ENES, THE GLOBALISTS
STICK TOGETHER.
THEY ARE PROTECTING CHINA.
WHEN IS THE LAST TIME WE HAD
THAT HOLLYWOOD BLOCKBUSTER ABOUT
MAO COMING OUT.
THAT'S NEVER GOING TO